hot breath another thing that i admire
about you is
your mindfulness around
learning and being a part of other
worlds besides just comedy we can
we can get single-minded as comedians to
be like it's all comedy all the time but
you're very intentional about
learning from different worlds and being
in different worlds
and i recently heard you say in an
interview that you've learned more
about the business from like rap and
wrestling than you have from
anything within comedy and i'd be
interested to know what are some of the
business
things you've learned from rap and
wrestling that you apply to your comedy
oh thank you for asking that um i think
in comedy we a lot of us get this
mindset of like oh
we're pure artists we just want to do
stand up like so many
my friends i'd even talk to and they'd
be like why do you want to do voice
acting why you want to do like
like stand up is the purity and as i
think if anyone sees right now
diversifying your portfolio is a
god because there's no stage for you to
hit right now
but however i'm still getting checks
from trolls
but i don't that's either here nor there
but
a lot of the business i learned from
from rap
and from from um wrestling was
self-promotion about making yourself
seem like a big deal
that if if you made yourself seem like a
big deal
no one's going to believe you are a big
deal until you do and so
a lot of my like i would post about my
shows i would post about what's going on
even if they were half full
i would just take pictures i would post
about them
because i was like you want to be a part
of this the people the half full room
that was here
they loved it you should be here they
are the cool people
and then a lot of it was like selling
t-shirts and selling posters
like when i started doing that a lot of
it was kind of
looked down upon that it was corny that
it was hacky that it was that's what
rogue comics do
but i knew every time i went to a
wrestling show
every time i went to a rap show i wanted
to leave with that
artist's t-shirt because i wanted to
support them because i wanted to
i thought it was cool if i came back
with a currency shirt or a
devin the dude shirt or whatever like
and i thought it was weird that comics
didn't
seem look at it like that and so i
wanted i got into merge more i got into
self-promotion more and i got into
making like little commercials for my
for my runs for my um tour like
i said they're doing that a couple years
ago and a lot of my comedian peers were
making fun of me like why are you doing
that
you know you're wasting your time
they're stupid they're low budget
they look weird but i like i love low
budget commercials it is a little it's a
local commercial for like hey i'm coming
to your town
and i you not like a year
later clubs were requiring that i
send them a video and then my and then i
started seeing oh my peers are making
commercials now
like and i was like oh you were you were
the one making fun of me
and so i was like you know when it comes
to business i don't like to be a
follower i like to
to be a leader i like to think about
what
we could do different what we can do
better that's one thing i'm doing right
now i'm partnering with this
company prowrestlingtees.com and they've
been a big help in the pro wrestling
community we're helping
independent contractors independent
wrestlers sell their own merch
online they provide the t-shirts they
provide
like the shipping they provide
everything you just provide the art and
you set the price point
and it's been such a godsend for the
wrestling community i was like why don't
we have this for comedians we probably
sell more shirts than wrestlers
and so now we're starting at we got a
small group of people me
adam ray brad williams billy wayne davis
jackie fabulous beth stellen and
we're starting like a comedy wrestling
tease with with the pro wrestling tease
guy
so uh because i think it can work for
comedians of all levels because they
don't
when i started selling merch like they
they would make you
buy a bulk order or t-shirts i remember
i was selling with some small company
and i sold like 300 shirts and they sent
me a bill
and i was like what's going on you know
so
um luckily i start because of my love of
pro wrestling i was able to talk to this
other company that was like hey that's
ridiculous like
you'll never you come hang out with us
you'll never get a bill
for selling a shirt like you might you
know only get five ten dollars if you
sell one shirt that month but
you'll never get a bill and so i've been
working with them and building that
relationship ever since
you